I want to take just a couple of minutes
to tell you about a project we're
partnering with called blob flow and
they've sponsored this video one of the
biggest problems that crypto currencies
like Bitcoin or aetherium have today may
be the biggest obstacle to mass adoption
is the volatility that we see in
individual crypto currencies when you
obtain crypto currency the value can
drastically change not just from year to
year but even month to month or week to
week and this is a big source of
skepticism about the viability of crypto
currency and its effectiveness as a
medium of exchange blob flow has
developed a crypto currency called a
blob be lob and the value of these blob
coins would be stabilized by baskets of
other Kryptos that are relatively stable
sort of the way that a mutual fund
fluctuates less than any individual
stock blob coins would be more stable
than any of their constituent crypto
currencies on which its value is based
as a whole hedging against the single
failure of any one of those coins the
utility governance token of the blob
flow project is called flow which and
the holders of the flow tokens are the
ones that decide the collateral
composition of those blob baskets which
makes blob a democratized form of money
anyone who uses the blob flow smart
contract to allocate their own
cryptocurrency assets to originate blobs
are also rewarded with flow tokens which
enable you to govern the blob stable
coin itself it's a fascinating project
that's trying to solve very real
problems in the crypto space and they're
doing it in a way that's meant to
democratically empower those who are
getting involved which as they see it
would in turn also make this a more
effective solution for achieving a
cryptocurrency that remains stable I
would encourage everybody to learn more
about what blob flow is up to they have
some exciting things going on
interesting partnerships the new version
of their white paper is worth looking at
you can find it all by going to blob
flow calm I've put a link
down below as usual any time I discuss
crypto currencies I am not giving
financial advice everybody should do
their own due diligence and research
before making any financial decision